we are here with Kaitlyn Bristowe on the
morning of her releasing this new song
Kaitlyn I feel like we have been talking
about this in interviews for years that
now it's funny to say F and daddy you
feel I know I feel like I've been
waiting for this moment since I was like
5 years old and it feels like the last
three years like really really been
waiting for this moment so I am so
overwhelmed today like within the best
way possible like I just feel a relief
that's so happy and it's been a lot of
positive feedback and that's a bit of a
shocker for me why is that a shocker
okay you know how we all do that thing
on Instagram where we compare ourselves
to other people in their lives like
that's what I was doing I was like well
I'm not Carrie Underwood I was comparing
myself to someone that's like completely
like just unrealistic goals for me
instead of being like you know I love
singing and I have a unique gift and I
was doing the comparison thing and so I
think people I thought people were gonna
say you suck good Titan sound like
Carrie Underwood
[Music]
you talked about this a little on
Instagram but tell me why right now was
the time we finally bit the bullet and
shared it with the world yeah I think
when I wrote it it was kind of in a time
where I was feeling really connected to
the importance of strength in a tough
time I was going through a hard time
when I wrote it
and since then it just the song felt a
little bit like dated in my mind because
I had just gone through so much and I'm
in such a good place and it just was
kind of on the back burner but then
listening to the lyrics again I'm
thinking you know isolation plays a big
part with mental health we're all kind
of both here so they'd hard together
we're all being so vulnerable with each
other and how we're feeling and I was
listening to the lyrics and I'm like wow
this actually applies to so many people
and how we're all feeling right now so I
was like why not release it I'm a big
what-if guy which I need to stop that
because I can't be like from what I have
on earth and I was like no this is if
isolation and Quarantine has taught us
anything it's the importance of time and
it's the importance of connection and I
think people who connect through music
well and and correct me if I'm wrong is
it hint number two number one in Canada
and two in the u.s. like I am you can
understand I don't even understand like
I don't believe it like brain can't
access the feelings of excitement that I
need to feel how does that feel for you
if you can put any words on it I don't
even have words the only words I have
here that I don't have words it's it's
just it feels surreal it feels
absolutely surreal
[Music]
what were you going through when you
wrote this um well this was about just
over a year and a half ago so actually
it was right before in the break up it
was nobody had known that I'm Sean and I
had broken up yet and it was kind of
like right before that in that time I
recorded the song the day that the news
came out of our breakup and so it was
another kind of importance for me to
show my own resilience to myself because
all I wanted to do is lay a Medic pride
that day my dad was in town from Canada
being there for me and I was like you
get your butt out of bed this is
something that you need to do you commit
it to and like it's gonna be so
empowering and my dad came with me and
we just sat in that studio and I laughed
and I cried and I recorded that song so
I think also when I hear it back I'm
like wow there's a lot of emotion in
that looking back now seeing the success
of it do you think oh I wish I'd
released it sooner it is right now feel
really right yeah no I I'm all about
timing timing to me is everything and I
think I think this time to me feels I
mean yeah there's part of me where I'm
like what was I so afraid of I should
have released it earlier but I'm glad I
waited and then it has a whole new
meaning to everybody else well you and I
have talked a lot about how you know you
find somebody great and you sort of
learn things about your past
relationship having all this separation
now when you look back like what do you
think about you know what this is why it
didn't work out and what kind of place
are you in about it now it feels like a
lifetime ago to be honest with you um so
much has happened since you know that I
mean that was under two years ago and so
much has happened I'm no stranger to
mental health and depressed and I think
once you rid yourself of certain things
that are causing you those you know
moments of sadness once you rid yourself
of those your life starts going on the
right path and once you surround
yourself with things that make you happy
things just kind of fall into place so I
mean looking back in the last two years
I'm like my scrunchie line really took
off I started my wine label I released
some music and I'm
continuing to love this podcasting life
so it just it really feels like a
lifetime ago I did wonder cuz like look
everybody has I have like dealt with
people in our lives who have had an
addiction issue at some point or had
some kind of mental battle at some point
do you look at yourself and and think
about okay here's how I've got to make
sure I don't go down that road again or
what preparations do you take or fears
or worries you have about maybe going to
those scary places again yeah I actually
felt like I was on that path at the end
of my last relationship and I saw myself
going down that spiral again of just
being completely insecure and not
feeling safe or loved or happy and where
I was at and feeling like I just
couldn't move forward there's something
holding me back and I did I did you know
at that point in my life I was able to
recognize that and and do what I needed
to do to move past it
and I think I just now have better tools
and understandings of myself that what I
need in life to be happy and deal with
the times when I'm not and and just I'm
putting myself first essentially and
that just feels like the right thing to
do when you're that depressed or that
low I feel like anything that makes you
numb could be appealing maybe that's
where the line came from maybe I drink a
little more wine than I should I can't
even remember what else feeling in that
moment but I think that's always a fear
of this to go just back into the darkest
place of your life that you've ever been
so I'm sure I'm sure
I don't think I would have let myself
get there again but I've obviously have
no idea
well what did keep you from it what kept
you from that dark place I think the two
breakups I actually think my breakup
with the guy that I lived in Germany
with was more significant than this last
one because I had nothing going for
myself I had completely given up all
hopes and dreams and I didn't have
anything like I was just relying on this
person emotionally and financially for
everything and so when that was done I
felt like I had absolutely nothing and
from that moment on I have been on like
a
really long and will continue to go on
the self-love journey so you've released
the song it's successful like
everything's just going so well but then
I do have to ask you know we see these
hilarious photos of you and Jason from
quarantine I think there was one a
couple days ago that said we're a
walking disaster ha ha yeah how are
things honestly so great and we both
feel extremely lucky and grateful you
say it every day that we're able to work
from home and do what we do so it's it's
I actually think I spend less time with
him and quarantine that I did before
cuz I sleep in past him in the morning
and then we like clean up at the end of
the night for a drink and then go to bed
like I see him less now so don't get me
wrong there are times where I'm like
could you blink quieter but like it
that's you know that's relationships
well are not meant to spend this much
time together they just aren't yeah I
don't care how much of a stage five
clinger you are you are not meant to
spend this much time with somebody so
yeah probably at the beginning we were
both having those thoughts of what if
but we have done a really great job of
navigating this quarantine together and
can we come up with like a pretty good
routine I think the last time you guys
came in and sat down with me in person
in LA Jason was very like we're locked
in I'm putting a ring on this how has
the quarantine affected any of those
potential plans you know it's wild and
I'm not just saying this and we all know
I would tell the truth is that it this
has brought us closer together it's we
have really supported each other in each
other's business and what we're doing
and he's such a help to me with you know
he's one of the smartest guys I know
he's helped me so much learn about the
business side of what I'm doing I've
helped him with creativity we've really
just like been a team through this and I
think we're starting to just think about
what's important in life and and I think
that's like we've had a little bit more
patience and forgiveness with each other
because of that let me tell you if
couples make it through quarantine and
you're not
could be and you're gonna make it
through anything in life does that mean
that quarantine was the icing on the
cake you know this relationship is it
yeah actually yeah it's if we were
sitting outside by the fire the other
night just having a glass of wine and we
both were like well I don't know we had
such a good day and I remember him just
be like should we look at rings and I
looked okay which we didn't we've done a
couple times but I don't think I'm gonna
get a quarantine proposal because I
don't want one Oh have you thought about
what kind of proposal you want yeah
think about it I just don't all I know
is I don't want it to be like live
somehow in front of people private you
already get that kind yeah but not yes
exactly I don't yeah a national
television again that's a one-time thing
but yeah I don't want it to be
quarantined but I want it to be private
[Music]